foreign
hi Jennifer how are you
I am just wonderful how are you today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world exactly
um hi Dave I am calling because I had
purchased the 2023 Kia Miro
and have complete buyer's remote remorse
after I got it
so I took it back and I got a 2019.
now I'm regretting that and I'm about
ready to just doll it give it back I
think it's too late to give it back and
just walk everywhere
how do I get out of all this mess that I
created
I mean is it is it realistic to walk
everywhere Jennifer are you just kind of
being funny
I'm just kind of being funny okay but
you're just tired of the car remorse of
all the decisions you've been making
exactly so how much do you owe on this
car
this new car thirty two thousand okay
and what's your household income
um my household income is 52 000. okay
well your buyer's remorse is logical
because it was a bad decision
so um I agree but your your past the
point of being able to return it because
you've owned it for a while correct
correct that is correct but a couple
weeks and so you're not sure you're
going to be selling it and likely taking
a loss
likely and then you're going to have to
get something cheap that you can afford
to drive do you have any money
um cash no okay do you have like a
mutual fund that's not in retirement or
do you have any money you can get your
hands on
no
all right what did you get rid of what
were you driving before
um
the 2007
I only owed 12 000 on
yeah that was probably about right with
the idea we were going to turn and get
that paid off
so you were about about where you needed
to be so we need to move back that
direction and there's probably going to
be some Financial pain involved like you
might lose a couple Grand in this move
back towards your old car right
correct and you'll probably finance that
into the deal and um when I do something
stupid and uh Jennifer I've done a lot
of stupid stuff a lot bigger than this
okay uh I always just call when I when
it costs me money I always just say
Dave's paying stupid tax
so I think Jennifer's getting ready to
pay some stupid tax
I believe so you got car fever and
instead of taking a cold shower you
bought a car
exactly yeah you get it yeah well I've
been there been there I've done it too I
know what it feels like and that's
that's what gives you that bad taste on
the back of your tongue called regret
right
exactly so
the good news is
um that you can fix this the bad news is
it's going to hurt and the good news is
you will learn the lesson so thoroughly
you will never do this crap again
oh yes you've already had enough
emotional pain to never do it again
hadn't you
be hard on yourself Jennifer I mean I
know it's frustrating and you're like oh
my gosh this is gonna cost me just like
Dave was just saying but you know but
but it happens right and so don't be
sitting here for months and months and
months just beating yourself up over it
either give yourself some Grace and
learn from it because that's the best I
mean that's really the best thing that
you can do is to say okay I'm never
gonna make that mistake again but what
you're saying Dave though for her today
for her to go yeah sell it sell it and
move down to a ten thousand dollar car
and take a loan out for the for the 10
grand You're Gonna Lose you're going to
take out for the 10 grand and you're
probably gonna be two grand in the hole
on this flip yeah flipping back out of
this because you probably paid retail
for it and you're probably not gonna get
retail for it on the flip so um
somewhere in there and that's the thing
so when I filed bankruptcy Jennifer I
did a whole lot Dumber things than
you've done I was 28 years old
um Rachel's right
um You don't be too hard on yourself but
I I do want to separate two things there
I was not hard on myself
I never said you're stupid the decision
though I did do some stupid stuff yes
and I wanted to be really hard on the
stupid butt decision yep where I never
go back there again but that's different
than being hard on you know carrying
around shame right right conviction is
different than shame conviction is I did
a stupid thing shame is I am stupid
and I am not personally stupid but I
have done some unbelievably stupid
things in my life I'm 62. I've had a lot
of chances at it you know so there you
go